[Music]
all right tonight we have even more big
breaking developments at our quest to
hold those who abused power those who
are corrupt accountable now as the DNI
chief John Radcliffe Declassified
infamous intelligence community
assessment annex on Russian and
appearance and we now know that it left
out key details about red flags that
they knew about Christopher Steele
including that he was fired as a source
for leaking to the FBI it also proves
how mr. super patriot James Comey misled
President Trump about the dirty dossier
it's salacious and unverified but he
signed the warrant earlier using the
dossier as the basis of his FISA
application he's signed three of them
this all comes as the Senate Judiciary
Committee has now authorized subpoenas
for over 50 government officials in the
crossfire hurricane investigation
joining me now with reaction Senate
Judiciary Committee chairman Lindsey
Graham you know senator you had
blockbuster testimony from rod
Rosenstein knowing what we know now
wouldn't find that that buys the
application we wouldn't have had the
country go through two and a half years
of hell with Muller we now know that the
FBI knew from its earliest dealings in
July in August of 2016 that Steele was a
Russian research project funded by
Clinton and the DNC FISA courts were
never told this information director ray
where are you he hasn't yet to turn over
those to the Senate slow-walking that
the House GOP we're going to get ten
criminal referrals in the next few days
about leaking misconduct and the Flynn
and crossfire hurricane case and this
DNI declassification I just mentioned I
would say senator that the American
people were not only lied to lied to
repeatedly and that these people we've
identified for over three years on this
show did everything we reported they did
and more yeah and nobody seems to give a
damn in the mainstream media yeah so
just think about the how much coverage
was given to the Muller investigation
two-and-a-half years twenty-five million
dollars so what do we know in January
2017 Comey basically provides president
a copy of the steel dossier and says to
the president I don't know if this is
true we can't verify it we just want you
to know about it that's the same
document that was used multiple times to
get a warrant against Carter page we're
come--and McCabe and others mokou me for
sure signed an affidavit to the court
saying it was reliable we know in
January 2017 that the FBI interviewed
the Russian sub source that provided all
the information to steel and he said the
dossier was a bunch of bar talk
unreliable hearsay so I have the tools
as chairman to get to the bottom of this
and I will is there anybody within the
FBI because I still believe that they
are still up there pin on that 99% of
them are good and decent people knowing
what you now know and we all know are
you confident that the people that abuse
their power the people that are corrupt
the people that knew and had
premeditated fraud in a FISA Court
people involved in trying to help Donald
Trump not win and those also then you
know lying to the FISA Court holder are
they going to be held accountable
Lindsay because I think I'd go to jail
yeah so let me let me ask the answer the
question you asked about people in the
FBI there was an FBI agent he thought
still wasn't very reliable because he
didn't trust still and a couple of them
tried to find out where the dossier
originated from and lo and behold they
were able to find the Russian who
supplied still with all the information
in the FBI the professional said it
sounds like Russian disinformation
there's a multiple page memo from the
interview of the Russian sub source in
January
basically shredding the reliability the
dossier the question is did anybody in
the FBI go to McCabe and Comey and say
oh by the way the document we've been
using for months to get a warrant is no
longer reliable I find it hard to
believe that nobody at the top was told
by the professionals in the organization
our case fell apart you had I thought
the biggest blockbuster
a testimony from rod Rosen Stein I want
you to explain what it told you and what
the next steps are and by the way you
were criticized because you people said
well he's not moving fast enough they
had to wait for the Horowitz report
taking forever we're still waiting for
the Durham report okay so there's a time
in place what did it tell you and what
are the next steps
you tell it tells me that Rosen Stein
signed a warrant application having no
idea what he was signing that he trusted
the system and the system should not
have been trusted it tells me that the
scope memo in August of 2017 allowing
Muller to investigate the Trump campaign
was written by the same people who lied
to the court so what am I going to do
I'm gonna call every person who signed
the warrant and ask them did you know
about the doctoring of an email did you
know that the FBI had learned that the
dossier was no longer reliable and I'm
sure most of them are going to say no I
don't believe McCabe in Comey could have
possibly not known that the dossier had
been rejected by the sub source I can't
believe the FBI's that poorly run that
the most important investigation in 30
years of a sitting president that nobody
told the top of the FBI oh by the way
our case fell apart and finally I'm not
gonna let for people who interviewed the
sub source for three months get blamed
for this
it's not fair to blame it on the under
links if in fact the people at the top
knew so at the end of the day is there
anything that you watch the coverage on
this program and our ensemble casts
there anything that we said that was
wrong that you see and is there anything
the rest of the mob and the media that
was saying about Trump and Russia Trump
and Russia did they say anything that
was right well all I can tell you is in
August 2017 I found I find no evidence
to suggest that anybody named in the
scope memo that there was any evidence
they were working with the Russians by
August of 2017 the Carter page warrant
application was completely destroyed by
the FBI interview of the sub source
January the fourth of 2017 they wanted
to drop general Flynn from crossfire
hurricane
but it was the seventh floor of the FBI
that insisted that he continued to be
investigated so every time there was a
stop sign they ran it every time there
was a sculpt or e information they
ignored it what caused all this I'm
going to get to the bottom of it and as
chairman I have the tools with the
subpoena I got to go I didn't have
before now based on all we know just all
we just know now and you're gonna get a
lot more information yeah is it wrong
for me to mischaracterize this as an
attempted coup by people and the highest
positions of power within the FBI and
our Intel community that seem like a is
that a fair statement that's what I see
well here's what I can tell you for sure
that the court was lied to repeatedly
and that the people had a bias against
Trump they acted on that bias and it
should never happen again and all I can
say if you care about the rule of law
you should want me to get to the bottom
of this here's what I think if it's
Trump nobody really cares on the Left
how you get him as long as you get him
but I care I care too because our
Constitution equal justice an
application of our laws all a man all in
Plano alright thank you Lindsey Graham